hey what's up guys my name is eterno and
welcome to episode 90 of game
programming unbelievable 90 episodes so
what we're gonna do today is basically
do what you guys want to do right and
that is well non-player characters I did
ask you guys to vote on my website here
and as you can see the poll seems to
have won for non player characters or
mops okay men you came second and
metro-system items I probably asked you
guys again once we complete mobs because
mobs are gonna be a multi-episode thing
obviously they don't take five seconds
to make but most of you 46% voted for
mobs so that's what that's what we're
gonna do all right
and this polls close now so don't bother
doing that and voting um again so right
so mobs right non-player characters AI
basically okay I'm not sure what kind of
AI we should implement right because um
again this is a video game like we could
do anything I think what I'm going to do
though what I'm gonna do is I'm actually
gonna add a few more mobs I might make
them different skins this looks awful by
the way player I I do like the new
aesthetic of the game but the player
sprite isn't isn't isn't great I will
fix him up though I think I'll just fix
him up bum off camera but yeah so what
I'm gonna do is just add a few more of
these guys for now I might make some
difference and most bright some again
you know off-camera and add them in but
I think the plan is going to be to show
you guys two kinds of AI right 1 AI is
just the AI that isn't really an AI
right it's just like um it's just a
short little script essentially that
just tell the character to just move
around randomly okay so you might stay
here for a while team I'll move over
here you know you might you might see
that kind of AI and like in like a
Pokemon game for example where the
characters kind of just stand there then
they move around and there might be
gardening or whatever and they just move
around but but not scripted moving
around ok random moving around ok and
then the other type i might actually
show you guys three types one other time
might be a waypoint type so they might
have waypoints at which they stand that
could be really cool actually I think
I'm gonna do the waypoint one so I'll
show you guys random movement Waypoint
movement and then pathfinding probably
using the a style path finding algorithm
because um it's it's quite simple well
actually that's a lie it's quite
complicated especially if you're new to
it but once you get it it's it's quite
simple and very powerful very efficient
very fast and it'll basically imagine if
there's a player if there's a mob right
over here where I'm kind of shooting
where my mouse pointer is if that guy
wants to get to you he's just going to
be able to walk around this entire
structure and get to you using the
shortest path possible that's
essentially a nice style search
algorithm so that stuff is used for
chasing essentially okay now that being
said today all we're going to cover that
that's what that was like an
introduction of what we're going to
cover now all I want to do today is
actually just make an actual type of mob
so in in our mob folder we've got a mob
Java class if we take a look at that
this is essentially the template or the
superclass it is an abstract class as
well for our mops okay and because of
that I'm actually sure why's an abstract
class it seems to be implementing
everything here I think we did use this
somewhere let me just let me just check
one thing because I think that we did
use oh do we use it no that's wrong huh
okay first of all in the player class
let's get rid of all this animation code
because we don't need it anymore just
gonna delete that because we simplified
everything by moving it essentially into
the animated sprite class and then back
in mob let's make sure that any entity
as well are entities yeah case entities
need to be well on earth what I want to
open Joan's entity class come on so
update I think it'd be fair to say that
all entities should be updated oh yeah
cuz we didn't make this abstract did we
I'm just trying to remember here I think
we try to but spawner didn't have up
there or something I don't know this is
like changing our entire structure let's
abstract this I think though
this particle spawning I'll have an
opt-out method yeah okay fair enough
that's right we don't have to mark them
ISM as abstract per se
especially not entities let's get rid of
this for now we will keep updating here
there all right whoops here that okay so
that's just taking a look at our
structure and of course in render for
the mob thing that should have a screen
screen and that'll make that arrow go
away
if we import this okay cool so mobs have
to be rendered and they have to be
updated and in fact I will just um make
this abstract as well so what is
abstract you guys might not know what
abstract is I was actually thinking I
was pondering the idea over my summer
break which is basically over the
Christmas break of making a um a Java a
java series essentially had a freaking
learn Java because a lot of people ask
me like I really wanna watch your videos
but again you assume that we have
minimum Java knowledge work and I
learned that Java knowledge and I keep
sending people to other channels and
that might not be um ideal because
obviously I can't guarantee the quality
of the content there so I might make a
quick Java series which basically
Catalan Java I guess wrote to Java I
don't know what to call it
Java programming a game programming no
chatter around 3d gathering and Java
programming I don't know but the
abstract just means that he doesn't have
to implement anything
okay so abstract means that instead of
implementing having an implementation
for this update method here we can have
it in any other class okay so basically
abstract just Marxist classes not having
to implement this method that's all it
is but obviously if we make this player
class and player class as you can see
it's not abstract it has to implement
all of the all of the abstract methods
that it extends from mob or it inherits
from mob it's kind of like an interface
kind of as if it was an interface that's
how you have to implement them anyway
that was a properly pretty poor
explanation but let's get it let's get
on with this so we've got all this stuff
in the point of making mob right because
at the moment we didn't have to so far
in our game we could just go from entity
let me open our entity class although
you guys know what I'm talking about we
could go straight from entity to entity
to player okay
and we careful the cotton player but the
reason I made mob is of course I guess
the future-proof now game I'm going to
keep it sustainable essentially right
because um we want to add mobs in the
future so now that now because we've got
this mob class if we want to make a mob
it is really simple okay so over here in
mob want to right click on the folder
hit will hit not hit go to right click
on the folder hitting you and then class
and I'm gonna type oh well I like to
call um I like to call my first mob
dummy and dummy is essentially just like
a test mob kind of thing so make sure
that it extends mob okay and as you can
see because mob is abstract and dummy
isn't we get a bunch of errors here and
it says that it must implement the
inherited abstract method
Mamta update and problem of the render
as well so if we add unimplemented
methods oh my goodness
why why Eclipse why are you doing this
I've gotten through everything either
due to compile errors of the progress
okay okay whatever we'll do it let's do
it ourselves so make sure that mob has
an update method and make sure that mob
has a render method with of course the
screen parameter here and that is it and
as you can see if we do that and
implement that then our error goes away
okay so once we've done that we should
probably give it a second constructor
and a mob doesn't have a constructor
neither does entity in fact so our does
okay so we can make our own constructor
really in the player we've got a nice
little constructor that as the keyboard
input clearly we don't need that but
what I will do is when we do create
dummy um a dummy mob let's make sure
that we actually adds a coordinate for
it to spawn out okay because that that's
just like a little thing that I like to
do okay awesome
so um the other thing is I keep pulling
these mobs right but just because that
turns gone really popular with like the
advent of Minecraft and everything there
really should probably be called NPCs
which is non player characters I just
like mob I think just rolls off the
tongue
better than saying NPC because NPC is
three syllables mob is one syllable so
on that's why I say mob honestly a mob
basically stands for a more mobile
entity so it's just
mobile that's why I give some it's best
playing on player character okay so
that's what I'm office just in case you
guys are wondering okay so once we've
done that we should set this sort X
equal to X multiplied by 16 which is the
same as shifted right left sorry four
places this is just this will just
there's just some bit level
optimizations that will actually speed
things up a little bit and they will
actually speed things up by the way I've
done extensive testing on this trust me
for university so yes now um let's say
probably not so much in this case by the
way before full lips especially I'm
using bitwise operators instead of
operators normal operators actually does
appear things up because some J Ras and
some compilers don't actually perform
those optimizations at compile time so
that's why it's important to make sure
that you do do that and and the other
thing is people like well why don't you
keep it um time 16 for readability right
because of course that's the same as
what I just wrote the thing is this is
this is actually not like this is more
readable to me this is as readable to me
if not more more readable I just like
the way it looks okay so that's uh
that's tool you guys are gonna get on my
case about that so player what else does
it have so update of course it needs to
actually have a sprite so make sure the
whisper in dummy let's just set the
sprite equal to right now to be sprite
dot playing now there there is um in
player I think we set it to animated
sprite don't we that what we do no we
don't not exactly
sprite equals okay set it to player
forward let's sit sprite equal to play a
forward right now because when animate
stuff today but we'll set Sparta equal
to play forward so update will do
absolutely nothing for now and in render
what we want to do is screen dot Brenda
player which changed as a render mob at
of course the x coordinate the y
coordinate with the sprite and flip Y is
flip even here I'll set this to false
what is flip do we use flip and a play
flip on flip right oh is that that's the
stuff that we used for mmm yeah okay
sorry for the follow that was the stuff
we used for before um we had enemies
Brian I think yeah okay so anyway I'm
yeah so what that should do of course is
when you do do this what it does is it
creates a new dummy object which of
course renders itself at that location
so what I'm gonna do right now is I'm
actually gonna ctrl click on the strain
to play method it's gonna open our
method over here what I'm gonna do the
more I right-click on it hit references
sorry my bad
hit refactor and rename okay or you can
hit alt shift our of course and what
this allows will allow us to do is
essentially rename this render play
class to whatever we want and it will
update it everywhere so obviously we
call the method render player multiple
times in our code and what we would have
to do if we just rename it we'd have to
actually copy and paste a name
everywhere so we'd have to change the
name to the new name everywhere by
refactoring it though it will update
everywhere so let's change this to
render mob instead of rather player ok
hit answer and as you can see if we go
back to our dummy this is immediately
change to render mob and if we go back
to that player class this has changed to
render month so that's why refactoring
is great and it's awesome for renaming
stuff among other things of course so
that's it
okay if we go into our spawn level which
is where we do stuff if and let's in in
just the spawn level thing let's
actually just add the entity into class
effect let's not confuse you guys we
where do we um what do we add stuff
where we are the player I don't even
know do a 2000 level I don't think so
okay doesn't matter in spawn level will
just get ad and then entity a of course
we'll just hit add new dummy and will
Adam at if I knew the coordinates that
would help
let's hit player quickly where do we add
the player we added the player at a tile
court in 1962 it seems so we'll do the
same thing here so we'll add a dummy at
let's just say 1920 and maybe like 55 so
it's just above the player don't support
that of course and that's it right so
let's launch and see what happens here
oh look at that we've got how old sprite
here but what we have
as you can see a mob and he doesn't move
right now but he can okay and next time
we're gonna cover some really basic
movement operations for this mob okay so
I hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
game programming if you did please hit
the like button again if this hits 200
likes I'll put out a video tomorrow if
this hits 300 likes within like 24 hours
then I will put two videos up tomorrow
okay
so yeah hit the like button I'll see you
guys later good bye
you